hier après ces annonces Élisabeth borne
étaient l'invité de France Info pour
assurer le service après-vente et
visiblement la personne chargée de la
maintenance informatique des écrans du
studio a eu 64 ans hier et est parti à
la retraite qui sont contre cette
réforme certains sont même dépassé par
la technicité de ce déballage de ce
sujet on peut avoir tendance à limiter
le débat à l'âge de départ à la retraite
j'ai été viré à cause de vous non c'est
pas vrai
une fois j'étais passé là j'avais parlé
de on était de pouvoir d'achat et puis
j'avais parlé des augmentations des
frais kilométriques d'ailleurs on en
avait parlé ensemble et puis
ça n'a pas plu à La Voix du Nord et donc
vous faisiez quoi là-bas je distribué
les journaux le matin alors aujourd'hui
figurez-vous que c'est la journée
mondiale du merci c'est la Journée
mondiale pour dire merci merci le public
merci merci à vous d'être fidèle tous
les jours à slam pas quand la personne
chargée des écrans sur France info je
suis occupe également du système
informatique de l'Assemblée nationale et
après
[Applaudissements]
problème technique ça sert à rien de
s'énerver alors j'ai un problème en face
à gauche
vous arrivez à gérer votre travail et
les tournages de l'émission comment vous
faites pour vous occuper de la fibre
optique dans le monde entier et être
présent avec nous je remercie mon chef
effectivement je pense qu'il faut quand
même s'arranger avec eux
on est dans le Nord donc je lui
ramènerai quelques bières et je pense
qu'il sera content tu as travaillé
combien d'années alors j'ai commencé à
16 ans
je travaille toujours donc vous calculez
ça fait 50 ans que tu travailles bah oui
50 ans que tu travailles Janine et tu
m'as dit un truc il y a un instant je
leur qui m'en fous tu m'as dit je mange
pas tous les jours mais non je ne peux
pas parce que je suis désolé mes
dernières courses et je les ai fait il y
a 2 jours j'ai même dit à la caissière
vous me verrez pas l'adresse du mois
parce que j'ai fait mes dernières
courses on peut pas comment tu t'amuses
on prend le Tamise et on zouk
pardon
[Musique]
j'ai des difficultés
concernant le contact social c'est la
raison pour laquelle je porte ce masque
je ne donne mon vrai nom et ne montre
mon vrai visage qu'au gens qui ont su
gagner ma confiance ce qui pourrait être
le cas si là où l'une d'entre vous
devient ce soir notre associé d'accord
en tout cas c'est original il y a un
plan très sûr que vous pouvez suivre
pour avoir le succès la prospérité la
longévité et la sérénité il y a trois
choses à faire trois choses
payez vos impôts
occupez-vous de vos oignons
white name
ne parlez pas de la femme de Will Smith
Nabila Nabilla elle le dit il y a des
personnes qui abusent beaucoup de la
science moi je ne sais plus quoi faire
je ne sais pourquoi nous rayon pourquoi
nous rions
parce qu'on peut encore un Xavier Dupont
de ligonnèse vous direz il y a des
personnes qui négligent beaucoup trop
leur famille et il aurait raison
[Musique]
Soraya on sait que vous êtes fan de
votre plastique mais n'abusez pas vous
voyez pas que Fabrice est au bord du
malaise
et regarde la texture comme elle est
horrible
bah horrible mais un peu trop liquide la
meringue chez Elodie qui va avoir du mal
à donner de la tenue à son cœur comme du
côté d'elsar en fait je suis en train de
lire c'était pas ça fallait que je fasse
il faut que je que j'ai oh non c'est pas
vrai au secours cette grande étude menée
auprès de 3500 étudiants suédois âgé en
moyenne de 25 ans on les a interrogés
pendant 9 mois sur leurs habitudes de
vie leur morales et leur tendance à la
procrastination c'est-à-dire remettre en
permanence à plus tard ce qu'on pourrait
faire tout de suite résultats au bout de
9 mois les chercheurs ont constaté que
ceux qui procrastine le plus ont
davantage de problèmes de santé un
sommeil de moins bonne qualité un risque
de dépression de mauvaises habitudes
alimentaires
[Musique]
et au final ça marche plutôt bien il y a
une meilleure ambiance tout le monde
rigole et Ilan il est super content
[Musique]
on a frôlé la catastrophe Soraya
heureusement que vous êtes équipé
d'airbag en série alors en fait c'est
pas la procrastination en tant que tel
qui cause directement les problèmes de
santé non en fait le fait de
procrastiner ça vous encourage aussi à
reporter par exemple des rendez-vous
médicaux à changer vos habitudes les
scientifiques ont constaté qu'environ
20% des adultes un adulte sur 5 peut
être considéré comme un procrastinateur
chronique vous n'êtes pas seul un
Pauline j'ai regardé en France 58% des
Français à vous pratiquez régulièrement
la procrastination
[Applaudissements]
tout en riant
je comprends qu'il parle pas bien
français on voit que vous savez
parfaitement de quoi vous parlez je
connais pas d'aliments qui sont
heureusement rôti de porc que les
tranches quand on les coupe elles sont
roses des crevettes la crevette c'est un
poisson se mange cru et cuit donc oui
c'est un poisson
[Rires]
qu'est-ce que vous dites
qu'est-ce qu'on fait
en situation en demande en général aux
gens de se serrer la main parce qu'on
est un peu en inversé donc vous allez
voir c'est aller vous êtes où là
Anthony
donc là on est un peu sombre évidemment
des débiles là préféré
et toi tu vas bientôt être mon chômeur
préféré
[Applaudissements]
la Fédération Française de Football a
décidé la mise en retraite de son
président Noël le Grecs le temps que
l'audit sur son comportement commandé
par le ministère des Sports rendent ses
conclusions son vice-président Philippe
Diallo assurera l'intérim je rappelle
qu'une interview dans laquelle Noël le
grecte expliquait qu'il n'avait rien à
secouer deux Zidane a fait scandale en
début de semaine